[Music]
this week we've got dramatic reporting
food add snacks in avatar series yeah
I've heard about the avatar meat - I'm
excited for that but let's go to number
one number one so for our first story
have you guys heard of hurricane
Florence yeah it's destroying the East
Coast these are still happening uh I
heard it was coming out a walking pace
like the pace that it's coming you can
actually like walk and Evita as long as
necessary the hurricane meteorologists
like Durga I've been reading that it's
not it's it's a big-ass hurricane but
it's not as dangerous as like the
southern ones cuz if you prep you can
leave but when you leave of course
they're gonna like wreck [ __ ] but you're
able to out walk in that's confusing
come on source usually they want us to
be scared
I'm not they're kidding because there
have been at least 37 dead maybe but
then we were taking a nap and a half
although they died because they were
just they didn't leave they were there I
know I know a lot of the deaths happen
because like trees fell on people's
houses cars some people were trying to
like do some back to the future' [ __ ]
and connect wires during the storm and
[ __ ] and gotta let you in yeah there's I
read the reports there's like those are
the same guys that are like in their
sixties and don't go to the doctor then
when weird stops it was a lot of old
people yeah there was like a guy that
was he went back to go check on his dogs
and [ __ ] and then on the way there he
got blown away by the wind and [ __ ] yeah
it's kind of funny but it's it happened
that's walking walking hurricane I think
I think what Bart is saying though is
like if you walk before the hurricane
comes then you could walk away from it
but when you're in it you're in it you
know like I saw some footage where this
person was recording a flood and it
looked like the ocean was at his [ __ ]
house like he's outside and then there's
just nothing but like water and just
waves just smashing around and then
hitting the neighbors safe weight like a
water house oh yeah
that's dry remember as a kid out of C
the news and I would see other cities
that get completely flooded right we're
like that you can't even see the top of
the cars and people had to canoe around
the neighborhood how fun is that yeah I
mean cut to now you're just like [ __ ]
that was actually really [ __ ] up
oh yeah [ __ ] ruined I think of anything
I would have wanted that because it
meant that I got days off of school like
for sure do you think it's [ __ ] up do
you guys think it's [ __ ] up to
vacation and a place that's flooded so
you know for what so because you want to
enjoy the flood like it's a canal in
California we never get our cool floods
right yeah so I'm like oh [ __ ] you
you see these fools over there they're
flooded as [ __ ] let's go over that rent
some jet skis and [ __ ] go around her
Akane relief you know jet ski I'll
answer that afterwards okay I think you
here are no I'm just saying that was do
you think it's [ __ ] up to go there and
you know ride the floods canoe around I
think so yeah because I think people
would be like oh no like all my
valuables are gone if you're having a
blast while people are like sitting on
top of poppy thing with their dog and
they're hungry as [ __ ] and you're just
running circles around them on a jet ski
but if you go there with a bunch of
water and you're riding on jet skis
that's not [ __ ] done because you're like
I'm here to rescue some people right
yeah a little tugboat or something yeah
how in your heart you could have fun but
you can't show it in your face yeah yeah
yeah cuz that's like going to a wart
once is what that would look like if
it's fun in your heart
[Music]
cuz I can't continue that's what is
gonna be the sunglasses on everyone
around you is like it's like fog yeah
they're like [ __ ] they're like holding
their dog and [ __ ] they're like in water
they're like hungry and you just like to
the rescue
alright so recently there was this
Weather Channel report where the
reporter was like bracing for his life
but then in the background you see some
oh yeah [ __ ] funny dude [ __ ] this it
does look pretty violent though until
you hit the gym or something
he probably lets you like a wind tunnel
it's funny yeah eyes were giants like
they're like eight feet tall
ya know and it didn't faze that
insurance wait yeah yeah yeah and now
this guy looks man we're trashing the
[ __ ] report that's pretty funny
though someone tweeted that video and
the caption it was so dramatic dude from
The Weather Channel bracing for his life
has two dudes just roll past hashtag
hurricane Florence I don't know maybe he
had hollow bones and he blows away
easily okie though I feel like these
news guys like their dreams were to
become actors or other things but then
they couldn't so then they did like the
second best thing and became like a
journalist or like some kind of reporter
well not a journalist but like these
kind of like Dario mortars yeah like at
local and then you know they can't wait
to put on their acting skills my
attention yeah well The Weather Channel
responded to this saying that it's
important to note that the two people in
the background that they were walking on
concrete but that the reporter he's
trying to maintain his footing by being
on the wet grass and also he was
reporting on air until 1:00 a.m. and so
he's very exhausted
also and also he's a little [ __ ] I
understand on concrete yeah it's a
straight cover-up yeah it's like why did
you choose or why'd you go on the
[ __ ] balance beam to record once you
go stand on the concrete where it's
[ __ ] safe there's another picture
like a meme that's floating around where
there's a city that was flooded or like
barely flooded and they had the reporter
find a big-ass hole so this hole
standing up to here in water and say
this place is flooded but then when you
look at the cameraman the water not the
shoes are still trying cuz they they
just stood in the dry area and I think
the report is that what it's gonna look
the most dramatic and they jump in the
theme yeah so it's like that's the news
though the fact that they had to make a
statement is what tells you that they
were covering their own asses because
they know that they need views and they
want you to watch as long as possible so
it's got to be a dangerous storm he's
gonna die yeah [ __ ] out of people have
been other videos for example as one
video in 2005 where there's reporter she
was in a canoe or like a kayak you see
people literally walk right past her
reporters are like like is it even it
was probably like an inch of water yeah
then she ends up covering up covering it
up by saying like oh but it's like it's
way more fun to be in a canoe than to
walk that's very true
I'm with her I gotta say if I was a news
reporter and I had a canoe on hand and
there was a puddle of water I would do
it I would if you're gonna lie just do a
better job and have people stay out of
your frame I know yeah it was funny to
koozie to see her or it's like barely
getting the proportion up it is like -
like are you hitting the ground that's
dope you have a life jacket on - just in
case yeah I feel like the mainstream
news is like getting more and more
called out by like by the minute no
one's believing it like none of no one
in our generation believes any of that
but like you know what the you know the
[ __ ] up thing is that's what people do
on YouTube all the time too
everybody with a lot like true but a lot
of people are smarter these days than
our parents so true alright for a next
story this woman in San Antonio Texas
she's selling this subscription box
service called hood rat snacks and um
sign me up Tiffany what's who rest max
like baloney and like what kind of hood
rat like a [ __ ] 40 ounce old English
with flamin hot cheetos the same thing
yeah I didn't know all hood words are
created equal they are those little
barrel deuce things with the with the
apple juice thing know like the little
barrel juice it like it's like a plastic
barrel and it's got like it's got the
aluminum at the top you could only get
those out like liquor stores
it's like kool-aid right there's also
like submit hose also like that there's
also like the bear or whatever with the
straw that's connected to it and then
you just pop it open that's what they're
called dude do have you never had one of
these or you probably seen it before
they see let me see
I hope I have I don't want to be left
out of the hood red circle I'd be left
out with you have no idea what this is
there we go circle yeah Wow okay that
means your parents care about you that's
what that means it's a drink
it's it like an alcoholic drinks no
there's no rest it's like their
fluorescence like kool-aid in a in a in
a bottle - it's like glow-in-the-dark
yeah there's this weird like aftertaste
like a diet
oh yeah that's part of me yeah it's good
that you never had it you're into
parents care do you know what talk about
the bear wine or like the one that's
connected the straws connected to and
you got to pop it open
hey glee I feel like I'd know it just
like it's like that it's just [ __ ]
water colored color water sugar in a
[ __ ] bottle yes this woman here she
is selling these hood rat snack boxes
because she moved from San Antonio to
Boston
for many years and during that time she
kept asking her family if they could
send her care packages of her hometown
favorite snacks and so she thought this
would be a great idea for other people
that are living in other parts of the
country or even the world and they can
have some San Antonio snacks so it's
like hot cheetos that was a hood red
snack I was thinking hot cheese yeah
that's why I said please wait
they don't have flaming hot cheetos all
over America oh yeah they do but I guess
it's like the combination of like
because I've never seen this alright big
red is a Texas thing I didn't start
drinking the pacheco and then this oh is
that the Bloody Mary yes this is like to
make a me to that I bought yeah so it's
like it's like it's like Mexican hood
rat stuff but it's perfect - yeah it's
like San Antonio they should have
regional like la hood rats anatolia yeah
when she said hood rat and then I heard
San Antonio in Boston I was like they
don't have hood rats there you like yeah
it's just so she missed like those
snacks specifically from her but she
called it hood rat snags like I was
thinking like it's dope yeah I was
thinking like I don't I don't know I
can't think of any like really cheap
snacks I wonder if they had Lucas too in
San Antonio
I don't make that anymore just go make
it they make it different
oh not the same I said Lucas yeah like
for example this I'm here you could see
like the yeah I love that
and then the mango - oh that black
cookie thing is bombed the openness the
caca what or not
how come they call him hoppin s oh
because well I look at these Japanese
right pan aye
from what I remember what I read there
was this Japanese dude that created it
when he was living in Mexico but and so
they're not from Japan but it's like a
Japanese do they created it when he was
imported cuz I've had something similar
to that in Japanese snacks it's like a
nut and then it's covered in that
crunchy thing yeah that's like caramel
or something right and then it's like I
don't know but it's like breaded type of
crisp like it's crunchy and it's covered
yeah in the peanut yeah when I was a kid
I thought they popped it you know like
that corn pops they go like they how
like they popped it so I thought they
threw a peanut and a popper and it
turned into that like corn nuts you know
I corner a pop you pop it Oh got this
note this is literally a peanut yep
what's the outer shell covering though
the Japanese yeah go through the outer
shell it's so this is peanuts that are
coated in wheat flour dough and then
fried or deep fry oh it's me pride Oh
Dan that's how I thought it was popped
as a kid you know what I look about
Mexican stuff they get the most
healthiest things and make it unknown as
oh yeah stay happy it's good though it's
like you get a cup of fruits but that's
not good enough you gotta add syrup you
gotta add chili you gotta add all kinds
of goodness to it salt yeah one time I
saw this Mexican family pick out a
bottle of Centrum and they poured it out
and then they got alright the Bott
multivitamin and then they put butter on
top of it and they put in the microwave
and they split it up recipe where you
should have been good but they just
added like two sticks of butter to the
woods and it was so bummed though you
haven't tried to try a bottle of Centrum
with good butter
anyway
yes that hurts myself because you know I
know that if you microwaved it and you
mix it with butter it was like melt you
know like it was like no that's how
Mexicans eat their multivitamin yeah but
butter yes you heard me their first
books that's all [ __ ] yeah that's
what you got wrong so you got wrong
already gonna take my job if you got the
gun I got you scrape the rust off and
they put it on the île up there that's
what that red powder actually is oh my
god this chili yeah so if you're
interested check out yeah yeah I want to
do my own hood rat snacks what I feel
like that's like that's like south hood
rat let latina hood rat Snacks
what is a la deuda noodles or she [ __ ]
up yeah she's gonna change the items oh
yeah so she'll probably have because I
would do that that cool a juice thing
like or kool-aid in a bottle kind of
thing I don't think you twist off the
cap yeah I would do something that's
like like ghetto hors d'oeuvres like
instead of like it's kind of like
Lunchables but then you just get like
baloney
yeah government I don't know man cheese
you asked me that she's like I would
only get it at my food principally
individually packed ones what are those
call sliced American cheese yeah I've
eaten a lot of cheese straight out of
the fridge yup yeah it's good that's our
version of string cheese
yeah right for our last story so netflix
has announced that they will be coming
out with an avatar live-action series
Avatar The Last Airbender live-action
series
yeah is it an Asian cast or no no but
the original creators of the cartoon are
gonna be creating this yes
oh the the original okay that's good
because Netflix likes to like necklace
actually just like ruin things yeah you
know I'm not even like an anime person I
don't want to lie stuff but I saw the
Death Note thing because like I wanted
to be like in the loop it was one of the
stupidest things I've ever seen a
live-action Death Note yes it was so bad
so bad I couldn't finish this so bad and
like that's the thing Netflix has all
this money and so they were like oh
we're gonna get reading it small people
to produce for us to make this content
but the thing is they are legitimately
not as experienced as the more expensive
people so like a lot of the stuff that
Netflix is putting money into it's not
that good well it's hit or miss right
they're just playing the volume game
yeah I saw battle royale 2 and I think
it was produced by Japan Netflix [ __ ]
horrible Oh battle royale 1 is amazing
two's been out for years it's bad that's
been out for like maybe Netflix didn't
produce it but it's just the I don't
know I just saw it on that battle route
3 I don't know maybe three maybe [ __ ]
up messes because they would note that
because that's a good-ass movie but let
me get back to the avatar though this
has been something that was like
non-stop I watched every single all the
books I even read the comics this [ __ ]
is the [ __ ] best man and then when
mr. M night Shyamalan Millan came out
with a live-action one I was like
alright I'm gonna give it a shot they're
not Asian characters okay that's okay
Aang was like he looked like a little
Mexican boy all of the all of the you
know the fire peoples were like as
Indian Patel of ahem yeah they're
supposed to be like it's supposed to be
like this like what do you call it like
a pseudo Asian world of it's it's it's
those characters elements yeah those
characters that those characters don't
even look Asian to me well that they
don't know it's supposed to be like me
to we're clearly black yeah it's
supposed to be like it's supposed to be
like like like
like Inuit and and Chinese Tibetan and
like any Chinese and like like it's kind
of like this fusion Asian planet and
because that guy looks black that girl
and the blue looks like Ethiopian the
guy in the back looks like you're Asian
because I've got a little bit blue eyes
oh yes I was gonna say they were like
they're like let's make I'm a day for
surprise like Asian cos and then oh
let's give them all blue eyes like I
don't but they're they're kind of like
angry looking right now they have softer
features and stuff like if you live yeah
this isn't the original this is like
them getting ready to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
oh they look like they're BOTS is
Dragonball do they let you into you or
do they not location to you a Dragonball
know it looks like a very it looks very
cartoony so it doesn't look like
anything that exists in real life yeah I
mean just culturally the clothes that
they're wearing all that stuff they're
ism yeah and then they do martial arts
and then they use a lot of like they're
inspired by a lot of Buddhism Taoism and
all those religions to create this
pseudo like world and so people expected
it to be a multicultural cast of a lot
of Asians oh I see what ended up
happening was all of the main characters
were all the good guys were white and
all the bad guys were Indian oh yes you
know and then the the it was funny
because like there's there's there's a
there's the Northern Water Tribe in the
Southern Water Tribe and those guys are
supposed to be like any went so the
background characters and everyone was
like Eskimo Inuit or whatever they're
called and then the main characters they
were wife oh no so that's people were
kind of pissed yeah and not only that
like I didn't care about that that too
much I was just like you better do it
justice and it sucked the movie sucked
so I think people were even more pissed
about that well that's the good news
here is that Netflix said that they're
not gonna super whitewash it like to do
with the movie oh thank goodness
that's what I want to see ya innocent by
the original people so it might actually
be good bring me as an extra man [ __ ]
yeah I'll be up with the dog flying dog
yeah I gained a lot of weight
[Music]